so last time uh we basically started the
in-depth study of uh sonar or ultrasonic
sensors and as usual we started with the
physics of it right so physics of
acoustic waves is what we started
studying so uh at a very high level we
said that the principle of operation of
uh all active sensors that we'll be
studying and specifically sonar it's uh
it's very simple principle so basically
you have a transmitter or an emitter
that sends out a signal
a signal goes into the environment it
hits the the targets or different parts
of the environment and some Echoes
reflect back and then the receiver part
of the sensor
collects those Echoes and then it needs
to process them somehow and determine
the range to each Target as well as the
bearing angle or direction of arrival to
each Target and then as as you do this
process repeat it for for multiple
targets you can then basically
reconstruct a 2d or 3D map of the scene
by basically placing these points
according to their range and their
direction of arrival into a common frame
of reference uh now uh we started going
in depth uh into the physics of it for
sonar so for sonar basically uh the
signals uh are acoustic waves uh at
ultrasound uh frequencies and uh we
first focused on the emitter or the uh
or the transducer that sends the signals
so these are essentially like uh uh
audio speakers but they work at high
frequency so the signals are not audible
to us but they're sound waves
essentially and we showed that
um
the beam pattern of uh the the wave that
is generated by uh ultrasonic emitter uh
in the case in general it can be
variable approximated the angular
dependency of it by the four-year
transform of the shape of the emitter
aperture right so in most cases the
aperture as we'll see today the
apertures that are used are basically
just uh
plain circular disks and in that case
you just take the 2D Fourier transform
of a 2d basically disk or a circle and
it turns out to be basically this this
bezel function that we showed
graphically it kind of shows uh uh uh uh
is is like this like this uh blue part
of the picture here basically your beam
pattern it has a main lobe where most of
the energy is focused and then you get a
number of the smaller side lobes around
it and the the main lobe uh basically it
has some beam angle that is two times
Theta zero so it goes from minus Theta 0
to Theta zero and Theta 0 is given by
this expression here which is the sine
inverse of some constant 0.61 times
velocity uh or speed of sound in that
Medium divided by a times F where f is
the the frequency of the ultrasonic wave
that you're generating basically it's
the frequency at which the the emitter
is vibrating and a is the radius of that
disc that is your transmitter or or the
emitter so it is desirable in most cases
it's a little application dependent as
we'll see but in most cases if you want
a good angular resolution you want to
basically Focus your beam as tightly as
possible so you wonder if Theta zero to
be small which means according to this
expression the denominator here should
be large which means either you go to
higher frequencies or you use larger
apertures to basically Focus your your
beam better
then of course we are interested in the
Echo not just what we transmit because
we need to process the echo to do
sensing with it and so we continued
along those lines we said okay you send
a ultrasonic uh wave and according to
this radiation pattern or beam pattern
it hits a Target if you assume your
target is a small this is just
assumption to for us to be able to
simplify the math
the the return Echo when the target is
pretty small you can very well
approximate it with a spherical waves
okay so you hit it with kind of like a
focused beam but what Echoes back to you
you can estimate it as spherical waves
and the spherical waves as we showed uh
basically their amplitude drops by one
over distance right so on the return
path the echo that's coming back towards
the the sensor there's going to be if
that range is rho on the return path
there is going to be a one over row one
over row attenuation basically just
according to the physics of the
spherical waves and then we said that
this if most of these uh components they
can operate both as a transmitter and a
receiver so if you have one of those
transducers then for collecting back the
echo the sensitivity of that is going to
have the exact same pattern angular
pattern as as a transmit because it's
the same physics basically so then you
get the same basically bezel function as
your sensitivity
maybe I should go to the slide here
because we can also look at the look at
the Expressions together
foreign
okay so then uh basically the
sensitivity of your uh
receiver s of theta is going to be the
exact same pattern as it's uh as a speed
pattern that it's radiating or emitting
um the same vessel function dependence
and uh but also there's a gain factor
and the gain Factor basically is a
measure of how much uh of the return
Echoes energy your receiver is
collecting and that is proportional to
its area the larger it is more of the
acoustic energy is captured by it right
it's it's directly proportional to the
area so that gain factor of the receiver
is some constant I'm calling it Zeta
times a squared so a squared is kind of
like a measure if it's if it's a uh
Circle basically of radius a
then Pi a squared is the area so I'm
just lumping in the pi into that
constant so some constant times a
squared is a measure of the gain of your
receiver so then what is the received
Echo at the end of the day so the echo
is
a multiplication of a bunch of factors
it of course return depends on the Range
and angle right those are the two
factors uh so this term here P of rho
and Theta is your transmitted beam
pattern right then it hits a Target and
the target would also have some acoustic
reflectivity right it does not uh Echo
back 100 percent of the energy that hits
it you know some materials absorb some
of the vibrations for instance right so
there's this Delta Factor that's a
number between 0 and 1 which is the
acoustic reflectivity of of the target
that's uh that we're hitting with the
acoustic wave then you get the one over
rho which is the attenuation according
to the spherical wave propagating back
to the sensor then you multiply by S of
theta which is the sensitivity the
directional sensitivity of your receiver
and finally you multiply by the game
Factor G right and that is the full
equation that gives you what is the
dependency of the echo that you collect
back
what's the dependency on range and
direction of arrival so is it how does
it depend on row how does it depend on
Theta and as you see here the dependency
on rhobe turns out to be a one over rho
squared okay so by square of the
distance to the Target we uh basically
lose signal and the dependency on the
angle of arrival or the bearing of the
the target is uh the square of this
basically bezel function okay now this
is extremely extremely useful equation
because first it's easy to evaluate
right we can plug in numbers into it
like everything should be known right if
you're analyzing a case you say oh I
want I'm designing a sensor I want to
see if I can detect a Target that is at
20 meters at a 30 degree varying angle
with a reflectivity or acoustic
reflectivity of 50 percent
so and then I have an emitter which has
an aperture radius of an inch let's say
and my frequency is 40 kilohertz okay
you plug in everything and then that
directly gives you what is the echo
amplitude that you collect back uh and
then uh that kind of uh it's it's a it's
a very easy way of determining okay am I
am I going to get enough signal to be
able to you know detect it successfully
or is it compared for instance to the
noise level of the electronics I'm I'm
working with is it going to be below
noise floor is it going to be above
noise floor so this kind of gives you a
first order a very easy you know first
order check off uh what you can detect
and what you're going to miss as a
function of range and bearing angle and
the reflectivity of the targets
so it's very very useful but also it's
extremely important to uh as you do
these types of analysis remember all the
assumptions that went into this right so
this equation there's a whole bunch of
assumptions as we were doing the
derivation we made a bunch of
assumptions and if one or some of those
are not valid for the case that you are
analyzing uh then your results might not
match what you get in reality so very
specifically for instance what were the
assumptions that went into this this
formula we assume the circular emitter
right if your emitter is not circular
well you're going to get a different
beam pattern uh what else did we assume
we assumed uh perfectly you know
harmonic sinusoidal waveform if your
waveform is some Broadband waveform with
other frequency components in it then
your radiation pattern is going to
change uh we assumed we are operating in
the far field so if you're doing near
field sensing well some of these
assumptions break down so it's it's
really really important and that's why
instead of like in one shot showing you
this expression and saying that's the
echo amplitude of a ultrasonic sensor I
really walk you through all the steps
from the very basic physics to here so
you see what assumptions were made and
for your specific studies if one of
those assumptions is not valid that's
fine you can go back and go to the point
where we made that assumption remove it
and continue the derivation without
making that assumption so very
specifically for instance if your
aperture shape is not a circle that's
fine you go take the Fourier transform
of whatever the shape of your aperture
is and use that formula instead of the
vessel function that we have here okay
so that's really really important and
it's really when uh
like this formula here in 1995 maybe 99
of you know typical cases it just works
fine and most people just use it and
they don't even you know bother or know
what the about the the assumptions that
that go into it but it's really that one
percent of the cases where things don't
work
and then somebody needs to figure out
why it didn't work that that requires
that the unique the in-depth knowledge
of you know all the physics and the
assumptions that went into it and that's
exactly that one percent is what
differentiates really really top
Engineers with others uh and that's why
we bother with the physics here
physics
so uh let's talk a little bit about uh
these uh transducers uh the emitters and
the receivers that are used
uh there's different technologies that
are used to build these transducers
specifically there's there's three main
types that are used for sensing one is
called electrostatic so these ones are
uh pretty uh high bandwidth and they
have good sensitivity they require very
high voltages to to derive so so you
might need like 100 volts or multiple
hundreds of volts to to derive them uh
um at Acoustic frequencies and they
cannot go to super high frequencies so
they're you're typically limited by
about like 150 to 200 kilohertz in terms
of operational frequency which is fine
for robotic sensing but for instance
they're not useful for uh for medical
ultrasound because they don't go high
enough in frequency then then you have
your piezoelectric transducers so these
operate based on the piezoelectric
effect
and they have low bandwidth because
piezoelectric Ceramics are typically
resonant so they only resonate at a very
sharp frequency band so that you can't
do Broadband sensing with these but they
don't require as as high a bias voltage
as the electrostatic and they can go
very high in operational frequency up to
a few megahertz
and finally you have your mems
transducers
these have very high bandwidth very good
sensitivity
and they can operate at extremely high
frequencies you can go up to tens of
megahertz with them uh super Compact and
uh they have all the benefits of the
mems processing like you can co-package
your electronics with a transducer in
one chip and so on and so forth the
drawback is in mems uh you cannot make
very big apertures so you you are
because of the process limitations
you're limited to small apertures which
as we know would then limit
basically your Beam with so with mems
you're going to get very small a which
means very large Theta zero and then the
trick people play to basically counter
that is in mems you can instead of one
emitting aperture you can generate an
array of them so a bunch of them very
closely packed together and then
effectively together they can act as a
larger aperture for you let's look at
and all three types by the way they can
operate as both transmitters and
receivers so these are by Direction can
be in principle bi-directional
transducers for you
um
there's no limitation on that side so
let's look at some pictures so you get a
better idea of what these look like so
here's electrostatic transducer
extremely simple construction uh so it's
there's basically a ring
and then inside there the ring is just
for structural purposes so you can mount
basically different pieces to it but the
key pieces there's a grooved metallic
plate and then there is a very thin foil
on top of it and the way this device
operates and here you get an idea of the
size you know compared to a quarter
there so these things are like an inch
or two in in in diameter and then if you
look at the cross section of the of the
groove and the the thin foil on top of
it so you get basically these Peaks and
valleys uh inside the the on top of the
groove plate and then the high voltage
is applied between that metallic foil
and the the metallic Groove plate so you
get your electrostatic force between the
two and the force can basically pull the
metallic foil into the groove so it when
it goes into the grooves it makes this
shape and then as you oscillate the
voltage you basically
vibrate the thin foil on top of the
groove plate and it generates these
circular basically waves on top of it
which then emit ultrasonic waves and
just to protect the foil because it's
very thin usually you put like a housing
or a grill on top of it so you can't you
know touch it or puncture it so that's
your electrostatic transducer and then
um
here's one example of a piezoelectric
also super simple construction so
basically this is a device in terms of
the size it's comparable to the
electrostatic it takes up a little more
volume the electrostatic is more flat
but in terms of the diameter it's very
simple similar and then if you look at
the cross section of this basically
these two darker
uh elements here those are the the Piezo
Ceramics and the way it's constructed
basically you sandwich your Piezo
Ceramics between two pieces of mass and
you put them in in tension with some
compression bolt right so there's some
tension applied or compression applied
to the to the Piezo Ceramics and then as
you apply a voltage to the to the
electrodes the voltage is applied to the
Piezo Ceramics and then they start
through the piezoelectric effect they
start vibrating at their resonance
frequency and then that vibration is
coupled to the mass so the mass vibrates
and then you can then Bond the mass to
some output phase which becomes
basically your emitter aperture right
and and here's an actual cross section
of of a device so you have your piezos
here and then that's the compression
bolt you have the two masses and at the
end of the day this top plate is what
you your
final aperture of the emitter or the
receiver is going to be okay so that's
Piezo and finally there's the mems and
here again you get a sense of the scale
you see how much smaller mems is
compared to the other two I mean it's
it's really really tiny and the aperture
hole on this particular device is just a
half a half a millimeter and there is a
lot actually packed into this tiny
package that's just a few millimeters by
a few millimeters so if you open it up
so the way it's constructed it's it's
actually like a double decker design so
on the top you have your uh your mems
device with the uh uh with the emitter
and at the bottom you have all the
electronics so you have you know your
waveform generator your amplifiers your
adcs your signal processing so this
basically uh you can co-package
everything in into a small chip and this
thing is the full sensor than not just a
transducer you can have everything in a
in a tiny package and then if you if you
zoom in and look into your aperture hole
under a microscope you see this tiny
mems membrane and then if you zoom in a
little more into that this tiny little
circle that is your emitter aperture
which is you know salt millimeter in in
dimensions and it's suspended with these
super thin uh you know Bridges and then
the principle of operation is exactly
like your electrostatic transducer so
basically this is your thin membrane and
then a voltage is Acro is applied at
alternating voltage between the membrane
and a fixed metallic surface so again
you get your electrostatic alternating
Force which causes vibrations of the
membrane up and down and then that's how
you generate your acoustic wave but
again the the point here is uh you have
to notice how small that aperture is uh
you can you can make an array of them as
I said but if you just use one like in
this device you get a tiny tiny aperture
which means this device would generate a
very broad uh Beam for you which for
some applications might be actually
desirable it's not necessarily a bad
thing so uh for instance if you just
want a proximity sensor for a a vehicle
parking assist sensor you typically want
them to have very broad beam patterns so
that no matter where you the the target
is you can detect it's its proximity the
price you pay is then you lose
sensitivity in in bearing right your
bearing angle estimation might not be as
as accurate any questions
yes
is that true the amplitude of the actual
acoustic wave here yes uh and and that's
also because you have just a tiny
surface that that is vibrating so you
just generate less energy basically
acoustic energy and energy is
proportional to the amplitude or the
square of the amplitude so yes you do
get less which which means also your you
your your range would be more limited
because you're not sending as much
energy out that's that's exactly right
okay so um so now we have we understand
the physics of of acoustic waves we also
looked at how these transducers are made
and and using different Technologies I
think we're ready to start looking at
the system
um architecture to understand at a
system level how an ultrasonic sensor
works the system block diagram is
extremely simple actually so uh
basically on the transmit side you have
some local oscillator that generates you
know the the base frequency for your
acoustic wave that you want to send then
you have a waveform generator we'll talk
more about this but typically don't just
send you know a pure harmonic you send a
some sort of a a pulse shape
then you want to amplify that and that's
your your amplifier in electronics and
as we said some of these transducers
like the electrostatic ones they require
very high voltages like 100 volts or
more in those cases you also have a high
voltage Transformer in the path so
that's just to get you to the very high
voltages you need because you can't
directly generate those in in
electronics and CMOS or something like
that you you basically uh get get help
with that with the Transformer effect
uh you couple that basically Amplified
waveform to your transducer uh here we
are showing one where uh the same
component is both the transmitter and
the receiver so you first transmit your
uh wave and then you also collect the
Echoes and The Echoes come to the
receiver path basically on the receiver
side also very simple you just amplify
it as as we do in any sensor usually the
first thing you want to do is to amplify
because you want to maximize your signal
to noise ratio then you apply some
filtering to get rid of out of out of
band noise and just keep you know the
frequency content that where you know
there is signal and then you digitize it
through an ADC and then you do some
processing in DSP to estimate your range
and varying angle and we'll talk about
the processing now note that this is
kind of like a generic block diagram the
specific systems might be different
from this in certain aspects so some of
them for instance might not have the
high voltage Transformer because for
instance if you have a mems device it
doesn't need High voltages to operate so
then you don't put the high voltage
Transformer in them or sometimes you
might have a separate transmitter and a
receiver as we'll see in some in some
cases you separate out your transducers
use one only for transmit use the other
only for receive but at a high level
basically this is this block diagram
captures the essential functions that
need to happen inside a sonar system
so um here's here's an example I think
uh we've all seen these uh uh uh
ultrasonic sensors in the in the bumpers
of the cars that are used for for
parking assist so these are the the tiny
you know circular indentations that you
see there's usually four of them on each
bumper uh so so those are ultrasonic
sensors and uh if you take one of them
out and look inside it uh um now we
fully understand at a system level
what's what so typically those have a
piezoelectric uh transducer which is
connected to some PCB here and then on
the PCB you have a a Transformer to
generate the high voltages and then you
have a silicon chip with all the
electronics and the electronics
basically is everything we showed in the
block diagram there's the oscillator
there's the the waveform generator and
then under the amplifiers on the
transmit and the receive side filter ADC
and possibly some some DSP on board to
to basically process the signals some of
them
who you know digitize signals and then
you can have a separate microcontroller
or some compute elsewhere that does the
processing for you
um so so that's what these like look
like and there's several companies that
make them this one is is from Bosch for
instance
okay so
um yes
some systems do simple ranging in the
analog domain correct yes
more about that yes and thanks for uh
pointing that out because I think I
skipped over it but uh so uh something
you're talking about this point right do
simple ranging in analog domain so uh
in some cases
um if you're not interested in doing
full mapping and for instance I think
one example is like the parking
assistances where you only want to
detect proximity okay you don't need to
go to the trouble of you know digitizing
your signal and then you know doing
fancy DSP on a microcontroller or
something like that what you can do is
in analog build very simple circuitry
that just do some thresholding on the on
the receive signal and if it goes above
a threshold they kind of say oh I'm
detecting something and this is the
range
we'll uh talk a little more about it uh
in a few minutes but basically Those
sensors are not usually extremely useful
for robotics except again if you are
interested in just a very simple
proximity detector but if you want to do
you know proper mapping with bearing
angle detection and things like that you
have to digitize your signal and do
something USB okay
so one thing we haven't talked about yet
is if I go back here so there's this
waveform generator here but what are
these waveforms that are used for sonar
sensing so uh there's two main
categories of waveforms that are used in
sonar
and first category is a short pulses so
some solar systems basically generate
finite duration short pulses so they're
somewhere between tens to hundreds of
microseconds and they send these pulses
so your transmitter basically sends a
pulse and then it's silent until all the
Echoes are received from that pulse and
then it sends another one so it's
periodically sending pulses but the
pulses are short so there is a final
duration that you transmit then you're
mostly silent okay and then you send
another pulse and then you send another
pulse so the waveforms are repetitive
series of finite duration pulses the
hardware and algorithms that are are
needed to generate the pulses and also
process The Echoes to do ranging and
bearing estimation are very simple and
this type of sonar is is called pulse
Echo sonar by the way
but it also comes with some drawbacks so
typically these systems are not very
robust to noise and interference and
also they're Limited in how many
measurements you can do per second
because most of the time you're not
transmitting anything you just send a
pulse you're listening for all the
Echoes and then you send another one so
that's sort of as we'll see limits how
many measurements you can do per second
then this the second category of
waveforms that are used those are
continuous waveforms so your transmitter
is continuously never stops it's
continuously transmitting uh waveforms
specifically in sonar these are called
continuous transmission frequency
modulated sonar
or ctfm sonar excuse me
um also called frequency modulated
continuous wave or fmcw sonar fmcw might
be familiar to you from radar
basically Community because that's
that's what these systems are called in
in radar but ctfm and fmcw exact same
principle basically the system is
continuously transmitting some frequency
modulated signals and we'll see exactly
what the frequency modulation is today
um
and uh there's certain benefits to this
I typically need less bandwidth uh the
average power that they send is is lower
because you're spreading out your
transmission over longer duration so you
don't need to send very high peak Powers
um so there's less you know
non-linearities and things like that in
the system you can do a higher number of
measurements per second as as we'll see
again because you're continuously
transmitting your signal you're not
limited to short pulses you will be more
robust to noise and interference in this
systems but this also comes with a bunch
of trade-offs so you need more complex
Hardware you would need more complex DSP
and certain types of movements in the
Target or platform might cause issues
for for these systems as as we'll see so
there's always
trade-offs right it's not like Paul Seco
is always better it's Superior always to
ctfm or ctfm is superior to pulse Echo
as the the thing is uh that for for Paul
psycho systems and here we are talking
uh in the context of sonar but exact
same thing as we'll see type of
waveforms are used in radar and lidar as
well
um what what really is that the main
drawback is the fact that the type of
DSP signal processing that you can do is
very limited in these systems
um and because of that
um they don't improve much over over
time because as over time you're coming
up with better algorithms you know more
interesting ways of you know doing
detections or denoising or filtering and
things like that and most of those are
not applicable to pulse ecosystems but
in CWU systems there's a lot more you
can do in DSP and because of that these
systems are in terms of the performance
or getting better and better and better
uh over time so there is a shift in the
uh in the performance and I think
eventually we might get to a point where
except for cases where you want to build
something which is very low cost or you
need very simple Hardware
um you might be kind of completely
ruling out eventually that's not where
we are today but eventually we might
completely phase out pulse ecosystems
for you know more advanced robotic
applications
okay uh so now we are going to study
these types of waveforms in detail and
also this the type of signal processing
associated with each of them starting
with pulse Echo ranging so how do you do
ranging later we'll we'll talk about
bearing or DOA estimation right now
we're just talking about how do you
estimate the range to the Target
so um in pulse ecosystems
uh there's there's two types of pulses
that are are used uh first one first
type or category of pulses they're
called narrowband pulses and those are
very easy to generate they don't take a
lot of uh you know frequency bandwidth
and they are typically more more robust
to noise again because they're they're
very you know uh um
low uh low bandwidth so you can filter
out your receive signal just at around
the bandwidth of of the pulse and reject
a lot of noise and then we have wideband
pulses
um so those again there's always
trade-offs right there's no no free
lunch ever when it comes to these uh
types of like sensing applications so
with wideband uh uh pulses you can get
better ranging resolution also you can
you can do some very interesting uh um
stuff so for instance because you uh
have a lot of frequency content in the
in the return Echo with the wideband
pulses uh you can use the that spectral
information to do some types of
classification so just by looking for
instance at the fft of the return Echo
uh you can classify different types of
of objects like human versus say a car
versus something else and this idea for
those of you who are familiar for
instance with the micro Doppler effect
in in radar this is kind of along those
lines but done in in sonar and also with
wideband you can get lower side lobes uh
in the in the in the in the beam pattern
uh okay so what are the drawbacks again
there's going to be to be more
complexity to the hardware and uh more
complexity to the two parts of the
signal processing if you want to do
fancy stuff like this let's look at some
of these pulses so begin an idea of what
they look like and
so uh there's uh
these plots the first two starting from
the left are narrow band pulses so the
neurovan pulses let's look at this this
middle one first basically what it is
it's just a pure sine wave right at a
fixed frequency 49.9 kilohertz with a
rectangular window applied to it so the
rectangular window basically determines
your pulse duration
and then within that duration you're
just sending a pure sine wave and that's
why it's a narrowband signal because
there's just most of the frequency is
going to be the the energy is going to
be at that
49.9 kilohertz frequency uh the the left
one is basically the same idea it's a
slightly lower frequency at 40 kilohertz
it's just that that uh the the window
applied to it or the pulse shape is more
smooth instead of like this sharp
rectangular one it's a smoother
basically Paul's shape applied to it so
those two are the two examples of narrow
band again there's tons and tons of like
different uh pulse shapes that that you
can you can come up with your own and
there's always you know some trade-off
and performance according to you know
the parameters of the pulse
um so it's not like these three this is
it you can you can always come up with
new ones and there's many of these and
this third one is a wideband pulse and
as you see it's it's basically just uh
well there's a bit of transient but it's
basically just this one pulse short
pulse that you're sending and that pulse
is just 10 microseconds
um
so it's kind of almost not exactly but
close to like what a Delta function
would be it's it's very you know very
narrow in time which means in frequency
it's going to be Broadband or White Band
okay
so um and then uh this is just one pause
so again remember the way the pulse Echo
sonar works is it it periodically sends
these right so if you look at like your
time axis what the TX is doing
T that's
that's clean it up what the TX is doing
uh so let's do like if it's a wideband
case so it's going to send one of those
pulses then it's silent then it will
send another one and another one and
when it's silent
that's where the receiver is collecting
Echoes and when all the Echoes are are
basically back uh then then you send
another one
um so so there's some periodicity to the
to the transmit
um but most of the time you're not
transmitting anything that's how pulse
Echo works
okay uh so how do we do ranging with
these uh with these pulses uh let's
let's let's talk about that so this
principle that I just told you you
transmit a pulse and then you just wait
for all the Echoes to come back and then
you transmit another one so this is
called uh uh um it's basically like a
TDM or time time division multiplexing
uh principle so you're kind of
multiplexing the the time between your
your transmit and then you're silent
you're just you know hearing back The
Echoes and how do you decide the the
periodicity of like when to send the
pulses uh it's typically fixed not not
adaptive and the way uh that's
calculated is that you decide on a
maximum detectable range call that row
Max okay and that you can calculate
based on the physics like that
expression we looked at which gives you
the echo amplitude you can plug in some
numbers onto it into it and find okay I
think that's the maximum range 10 meters
15 meters something that I can I can
detect based on the amplitude that's
coming back and what you think your
receiver can successfully process so if
that's your row Max the round trip delay
for that range so your Tau Max basically
is equal to what it's 2 times rho
Max
divided by
uh the speed of sound divided by V right
so that's the maximum round trip delay
time that that that you have and and
this is how much you want to wait
after sending each pulse so the pulses
that you send
you want to wait a Tau Max
between them to make sure all the all
the Echoes are back or if you invert
that like how many measurements you
would do per second that's one over Tau
right which is V over to row Max that's
the rate of measurement that your pulse
ecosystem would do
um
and then in terms of again how how do
you find uh your your range that's just
the time of flight principle so what we
need that the receiver needs to
calculate to to do ranging is this uh
Tau or or time of flight uh uh delay uh
and then you do speed of sound times
that divided by two remember y to divide
by 2 because tau is the round trip DeLay
So you divide by two to make it you just
do one-way delay and then multiply by
the speed of sound yes
decide on the row Max for it but is that
possible that your sounds can reflect on
a Surface that's further that route and
then it'll be processed in the next 10
seconds yes so I'm just going to repeat
the question so the question was okay so
we're going to decide on so some row Max
based on some calculation or you know
you you do some sort of analysis based
on the physics and you say okay I think
that's the maximum range that the system
can detect but there is always a risk as
as you said that you can have a very
strong acoustic reflector
at a distance longer than row Max okay
and and that would Echo a a signal back
that you still detect and it's a strong
enough
but that kind of messes up your
calculation because you assumed now
you're you're associating that Echo with
the pulse that was sent
after the original pulse right so your
Tau calculation is going to be
completely wrong and that's that's
exactly true it does happen and that's
why you're you're never Perfect Right
some of your range measurements are
completely wrong and this is one of the
effects that can introduce that kind of
error you always can have a very strong
reflector it's not the
the biggest Factor as we'll see there
are things that are much much worse than
this but every now and then yes you can
get something that is at some at a range
higher than the max range you assume
then you were designing your system and
algorithms and that could give you a
false positive detection basically
Okay so
how do we do ranging so we need to
estimate time of flight right and there
are two main type of algorithms that are
used in pulse Echo sonar when it comes
to the time-of-flight estimation uh one
is called threshold based ranging which
is the simplest thing one can do we'll
talk about it and then you can borrow an
idea from GPS and then you're studying
GPS there also you had to estimate time
of flight right and for GPS we use this
idea of matched filtering or correlation
to do
time of flight here it's the same thing
if you want to measure time of flight
one of the things you can do you can if
you transmit signals with good
autocorrelation properties at the
receive side you can correlate them with
uh with a replica of what you sent and
then the correlation Peak would be
proportional to the time of flight so
that's also another idea that we'll talk
about but let's talk about the the
simple one the threshold based ranging
extremely extremely simple idea so
basically what you do is uh here's your
P Echo so that received Echo either in
continuous time or after the ADC so
that's why you have the T or an N
version that n is the index after ADC
sampling and it's so your Echo is a
function of the range row and the
bearing angle or or DOA of the target
what you do in threshold based ranging
first you Rectify it
basically take like the absolute value
of it then you integrate that rectified
waveform
and you monitor the output of your
integrator as it's doing the integration
as soon as it crosses a set threshold
you say that's my detection and you
check the time at which your integrator
output crosses the threshold and you
declare that as your round trip time of
flight so graphically here's what's
happening uh so you have your Echo
waveform coming back it hits the
receiver at time Tau so this tau is is
the is the ground truth
time of flight that you want to estimate
right that's the actual physical time of
flight that's when you start receiving
the echo right then you Rectify this uh
so this is the absolute value of your
waveform
um the rectified version and then you
pass this rectified waveform to an
integrator so what happens is that well
it's it's there's nothing out of the
integrator until you get some signal and
then you kind of start integrating and
at some point the output of your
integrator crosses a threshold and then
at that point you check what time it is
that's Tau hat and that's your estimate
of the time of or the round trip time of
flight so right off the bat you see that
it is a very simple algorithm but it has
a big problem which is your Tau hat is
never going to be the same as Tau
there's always going to take a little
bit of time for the integrator to cross
the threshold so it is always a biased
estimator right that's very important to
note you never get a
a perfect estimation out of this and
it's always biased
what makes matter is a little worse with
this uh
uh detector is that not only your
estimate is always biased but also
um it it that this error in your
estimation and the error is the Delta
Tau which is Tau hat minus the ground
truth tau is also a function of the
strength of the echo that you receive so
if you have a weaker Target either
weaker reflective reflectivity Target or
a Target that is
at a further distance because we know
Echo amplitude is also proportional to
one over range of squared so you get a
smaller amplitude Echo for fair their
way Target so if you have another Target
with a smaller I'm just going to Overlay
it in green with a smaller Echo
amplitude and you pass it through the
same integrator it's going to do the
same thing but it's going to pass
because it's a it's a it's a weaker
signal it's going to pass the Threshold
at a much later time so this is going to
be the tauhat 2 of the of the green
signal so your your
basically error in estimation is going
to get worse and worse either when the
for further away targets or the targets
that are less reflective
um so so it's it's not a great estimator
so if you want you know applications
I'll be with you in a second
applications which need you know precise
ranging you shouldn't use the threshold
base yes
application how would you go about
sensing like two different targets
question so uh the question is what if
what if you have Echoes from more than
one target right
um so two cases can happen if you have
more than one target either they are at
the same range but at different angles
okay
which means basically uh yeah at the
same time that you have this PE there's
a second target that
whose Echo is is hitting the receiver at
the exact same time and with that
there's no way you can distinguish them
right because you get the sum of the two
and then you cannot tell you just detect
it as one target
the second case is if the targets are at
different ranges so if there are
different ranges The Echoes are gonna
get to you at different times so you you
receive the first Target and then a bit
of time goes by and then you you receive
another Echo this you can detect but
what you would need to do and that's
actually what good receivers do is that
at the output of this integrator
as soon as it crosses a threshold which
we call a Target detection they reset
the integrator so it crosses the
threshold they reset it go back to zero
and then integrate again so if another
Echo comes you can detect it okay
so so you see right off the bat this
comes with very serious limitations but
it's actually even worse than that as as
we'll see so so always biased and also
your time of flight estimate determine
depends on the echo amplitude so Echo
amplitude is as We Know by the analysis
that that that we did last time uh it
depends on a bunch of factors uh one is
the basically acoustic reflectivity of
the target how much of the energy it uh
Echoes back then there is range because
there's a one over rho squared
dependency on the echo amplitude the
third one is angle dependency right that
bezel function dependency for instance
is uh determines also the reflectivity
or the echo amplitude not the
reflectivity the equal amplitude of the
target so targets that are at larger
varying angles uh we get much weaker
signals from them and with this type of
detection weaker signal means bigger
error in in your ranging estimate so
let's study that I think it's important
to understand that how serious
especially that bearing angle dependency
uh of the ranging error is for this type
of detector so to do that we need a
signal model
uh the uh kind of like our physics
accurate signal model is uh this uh
expression that we derived for the echo
amplitude I'm gonna factor out the range
dependency so let's say we're looking at
Targets at a fixed range row
okay we also fix our frequency and other
parameters we're just going to look as a
function of theta which is the bearing
angle to the Target if you just hold
your target at a fixed range and just
change the angle
how is the error in our ranging going to
change as a function of theta so the
Theta dependency of the echo amplitude
is this square of the bezel function
that we derived this is a pretty
accurate signal model but it's difficult
to work with we don't want to work with
bezel functions when it comes to this
type of analysis so again remember
everything else is is lumped into this
P0 so P0 has your aperture geometry
frequency the row squared all of that
but you're fixing all of those just
focusing on varying Theta which is the
DOA angle
so to get something that is easier to
work with it turns out that so this uh
this bezel function squared thingy
remember as a function of theta it has a
main lobe
and then it has a bunch of smaller side
lobes
right and the main lobe if this is theta
equals to zero it's between plus Theta
zero and minus Theta zero right now it
turns out that the main lobe of this
can be very well approximated by a
gaussian function so basically for
thetas that are in the main lobe less
than Theta zero you can approximate your
Echo amplitude by the P0 transa
gaussian function which is minus Theta
squared over to Sigma squared what is
Sigma Sigma is just the variance of the
gaussian and it's chosen such that the
width of the gaussian matches the width
of your Echo amplitude basically so
graphically this is what it looks like
so this is for an a real transducer that
I I did this the transducer had a
aperture radius of 1.8 centimeters it
was operating at a frequency of 50
kilohertz so
those numbers you plug into the bezel
function and you plot it and the blue
curve is the actual you know angular
dependency of your acular of your Echo
amplitude
and then the red is a gaussian that I I
fit to it and as you see for thetas that
are
between say plus and minus 10 degrees
the red and the blue are almost on top
of each other so we can use the gaussian
function as our signal model to analyze
our ranging error it's much much easier
to work with okay
so let's see then how the error in
ranging for the simple threshold based
detector varies as a function of the
angle of arrival or the bearing angle so
the way we do that we need to basically
the detection criteria remember is the
output of our integrator crossing a
threshold right so let's look at that if
this we call the I of theta and T the
output of the integrator which is
basically the integral from 0 to T of
the absolute value of the echo amplitude
or the rectified Echo amplitude right
now we're going to make one more
simplification here again just to get a
signal model we can analytically uh you
know play with remember if I sketch it
here the rectified Echo amplitude if
it looked something like this right for
like one of those narrow band uh pulses
that that we were working with we are
going to approximate that by just a
rectangular pulse of constant amplitude
Okay why because then the integral we
can do analytically and and look at the
results easily so what happens is that
so so the amplitude we call that just uh
P echo of theta right we take that out
of the integral and then the integral so
it starts at time Tau which is the time
of arrival actually of the pulse and
we're integrating over T right so then
you integrate from Tau to T of just T so
so then the result is basically this
what we have plugged in well P0 is just
that constant that lumps in range and
you know geometry and frequency and all
that we have our
gaussian approximation to p e of theta
okay so that's e to the minus Theta
squared over 2 Sigma squared and this T
minus tau is the is the out basically
the integral right so this now is now we
have an analytical formula for the
output of our integrator and then
remember as soon as this I crosses a
threshold that's where we declare a
detection so when your I of
T and some tauhat equals the threshold
that we call Big T that is the time the
time of arrival basically for us
so then just we just use this expression
here for I and we solve for our estimate
Tau hat of the round trip delay and this
is what you get so your Tau hat is the
the true ground truth Tau plus this
error term
that's your estimation error and as you
see uh it depends on a bunch of things
right it of course it depends on your
threshold
right and it seems like okay this tells
me if I want a low estimation error I
should choose
a threshold as low enough why not even
set it to zero right why not
set it to zero error term goes away
everybody happy right equals Tau why not
do that
yeah
well because uh there's always noise
right so the output of your integrator
is is always greater than zero because
even even when you haven't received any
Echo there's you know noises and a
little bit of interferences and other
effects so I mean the picture we're
looking at here everything you know
looks nice and ideal but you can never
have a zero threshold because if you set
your threshold too low any bit of you
know noisy Spike or something that is
randomly generated in the system causes
that output to go to zero so you're
going to get a ton of false positives
basically if you set your detection
threshold to zero so bad idea we don't
want to mess with t too much you usually
even set it a bit conservatively to
limit your false positives what else P0
we want large right and P0 is basically
a measure of like the the amount of echo
you get back from the target so stronger
targets are good right those give you
big P Zeros closer targets are good
right those give you big P0 but it's not
really a design parameter right it is it
is what it is according to the distance
and the the acoustic reflectivity of the
Target and then you have this really
really concerning term here and as you
see your error is exponential in Theta
squared so as you make your angle of
arrival larger and larger this error
term can really really blow up and
that's actually what what happens
um when you do that uh if if you want to
instead of like thinking in terms of the
Tau if you want to actually think in
terms of the range error that you make
in meters for instance we can convert
convert that to range with a with a
simple you know our time of flight
conversion so Delta rho is the area that
you make in ranging and that would be
speed of sound times Delta Tau right
your actual your estimate of that round
trip time of flight minus the actual
time of flight times two and then we
plug in our expression for tauhat this
is what we get so the the range error in
meters is given by this expression the
Theta dependency is the same right so
it's it depends on the E to the Theta
squared over uh two Sigma squared so if
you plot this we'll see it can be really
really uh
uh a big issue in in certain cases so
what we're plotting here we're looking
at the ranging error
right the air in the in the range
estimate as a function of the bearing
angle of a Target you're looking at two
different targets one is a target of
very high acoustic reflectivity like a
wall the other one is a target with a
very low acoustic reflectivity like a
like a a thin pole for instance and both
are at the same range so we're fixing
row at 1.5 meters and you're just
changing the angle of the targets right
so the difference is one of the targets
has a very large P0 and that's the wall
for instance and one of them has a very
small P0 which is the pole that's the
reflectivity of the Target and then we
look at the error as a function of theta
and if you look at the one for for the
pole even for a 10 degree angle of
arrival your you can be a meter off
in your range estimate
for a 15 or 12 degree I mean this thing
blows exponentially right so 15 degrees
it's
it can be many many meters so that can
be a big big issue for targets that are
have a high reflectivity is not as bad
right and again why is it not as bad
because this one over P0 term in the
error term so if your P0 is large that
really limits your ranging error and
that's why for a while you can be it can
be at 15 degrees and you still estimate
the range pretty much correctly and it's
really like Beyond 20 degrees that
you're or Beyond 15 degrees that your
errors for a very strong Target start to
blow up as a function of angle
so again we did
we did analysis and just to show you the
simple threshold base ranging works but
it has very significant drawbacks so if
you're working on an application where
you need accurate ranging accurate
mapping you don't want to do this
probably this is not the best algorithm
to work with
any questions
all right so
the second type of algorithm you could
use for a
um
pulse Echo sonar is doing match filter
ranging so let's just remind ourselves
when we were talking about the GPS
we did this very general derivation if
you remember that that he said if you
have some transmitter
that is transmitting some signal X of t
and then you have a receiver
that receives some attenuated and
delayed version of X of T like Alpha
times x of T minus Tau
and you want to estimate Tau
and if you set your uh basically
criteria as minimizing the mean squared
error in your estimation of Tau then the
optimal detector is what we call a
matched filter and what a match filter
does is that it takes the correlation of
your received waveform with a copy of
the transmitted waveform you evaluate
the correlation you look you find the
peak and where that Peak happens is your
minimum mean squared error estimate of
the time-of-flight delay right exact
same thing you can do for sonar except
now your transmitter and receiver are
co-located and your tau is the round
trip delay instead of the one-way delay
between the transmitter and the receiver
right but the exact same thing so you
receive some Echo waveform
right and that because you transmitted
it yourself you know what waveform it is
so you can also generate a local replica
of it correlate the two right and then
find the peak in your correlation which
is the arc Max of the correlation
squared or the absolute value of the
correlation and then that gives you your
round trip time of flight estimate
um exact same again math and Principle
as what we did in GPS so I'm not going
to spend too much time on it again the F
sub s is your ADC sampling rate and n
hat tau is the discretized index
corresponding to your actual time of
flight so it's the floor of Tau over T
sub s where T sub s is the sampling
sampling interval and again we all know
that the correlation is given by this
basically linear filter here here I
think I'm dropping a constant Factor
here like that 1 over k thing I've I've
just dropped it because it doesn't
matter if you're just looking for a peak
right you don't need to really include
that but that's that's what it is now
this works much much much better than a
uh a simple threshold based detector uh
of course it needs more more complex
processing but I mean it's a it's a
filter I mean these days in on any even
tiny micro processor can can handle
these types of uh calculations
one thing that is a source of error for
so this is for instance this it's
unbiased it's it's much much less
sensitive to uh you know the angle of
arrival or the range of your target you
know it doesn't have all those drawbacks
of simple threshold based but note that
one thing that still is a source of
error even with the match filtering is
that because of the physics of acoustic
waves
your waves get distorted The Echoes that
you receive back get distorted according
to for instance the angle of arrival so
the waveform that you receive
in some cases doesn't perfectly match
what you transmitted so there can be a
little bit of distortion between the two
which degrades the quality of the the
correlation if the two waveforms are not
you know uh perfect matches your your
correlation can can degrade so your your
Peak can be a little weaker nevertheless
this works uh beautifully
and as exactly was the case for GPS
the ideal if you want to use this scheme
of mesh filtering the ideal waveforms to
transmit are going to be waveforms that
have good correlation properties right
so in the case of GPS we saw m sequences
where uh very desirable it turns out
that for sonar M sequences are Overkill
I mean these sequences are can be very
long and I mean they're good for very
long distance ranging sonar you just
need to you know do a a few meters so
there's some much simpler codes that
exist that are used in in sonar same
principle these are just waveforms with
good autocorrelation properties but for
instance marker codes are type of
ranging codes that are common in in
sonar they operate again in the same way
as M sequences they're just shorter
duration and uh more proper for short
distance ranging uh the this this should
be very familiar how you do your match
filter ranging again you receive your
Echo you pass it through a correlator
you correlate it with your local replica
of the waveform that you're have
transmitted you get your correlation out
and then you square it you take your
absolute value you find the peak and the
index corresponding to that Peak that is
the discretized index for your Tau and
then you do your Tau hat which is
basically an hat towel
times your sampling interval TS and then
you convert Tau hat to row hat which is
your range right so that's how it works
and again uh most common type of uh
codes that are used or waveforms that
are used for this type of sonar there
card Parker codes which are signals with
good correlation properties yes
uh oh this this down here White Band
waveforms uh well it's actually so maybe
maybe I should have written it the other
way so waveforms with good
autocorrelation are desirable we agree
with that they just turn out to be White
Band
signals that have good correlation
properties they always tend to be wide
band signals so that's why uh this is
written that way questions
yes
affected by the annual how how is the
performance effectively not as bad as
the thresholding so the question is is
this technique is match filtered ranging
also does it degrade with angle of
arrival a little bit not as bad like
exponentially blowing up like the
threshold base and the reason it
degrades a little bit is because there
is some Distortion in the waveforms that
are angle dependent so at steep angles
of arrivals the echo that you receive
back the waveform has some Distortion in
it and that degrades the quality of the
correlation so essentially like instead
of if you look at your absolute value of
r p
times P hat uh like for uh
small angles of arrivals it can give you
like a very sharp Peak and then when
your angle of arrival is larger it the
peak can be a little you know not as
tall or not as sharp but still it's not
like the area is going to blow up like
the case of a threshold based ranging so
this is still much much better way of
doing
um doing ranging
Okay so
this was a for for pulse Echo sonar now
we want to talk about the second
category of waveforms which were these
continuous uh waveforms that are used
for uh sonar ranging so
specifically as we said uh the waveforms
that are used in ctfm sonar are
frequency modulated and there's a very
very interesting clever type of
frequency modulation that is used in
these waveforms and they are called
linear frequency chips okay so what the
signal waveform looks like that a ctfm
system sends let's call it sft and it
has this very simple expression e to the
J 2 pi F0 plus b t over 2 times t Okay
so let's let's break this down so you
have some start frequency F0 of your
waveform right and then this B here is a
constant called the slew rate
okay so what this is
um let me clean this up a little bit and
let's call this term here everything
it's a face term right so let's call
that Phi of T so my sft
is equal to e to the J Phi of T right
now let's find the instantaneous
frequency of this signal sft by
definition the instantaneous frequency
of the signal let's call that f is equal
to the 1 over 2 pi times the derivative
of its face right that's the definition
of the stantonian instantaneous
frequency so it's 1 over 2 pi D Phi DT
right so for instance a Phi of T if my S
was simply
e to the J 2 pi F 0 t then according to
this formula here it's instantaneous
frequency would be just F0 which we know
is true right this is a slightly more
complicated but not too bad uh we can we
can take the we can take the derivative
together of that Phi what it gives you
after dividing by 2 pi it gives you an F
so there's a 2 pi F 0 t the derivative
of that divided by 2 pi is just F 0 and
then you have a 2 pi times b t squared
over 2 right and you take the derivative
of that and then that gives you a plus
BT
right so your frequency you see it it
has it starts at F0 and it linearly goes
up or down according to the what B is
positive or negative over time that's
why it's called a linear frequency chair
uh graphically they look like this so a
transmitted waveform so this is for a
positive B what I've plotted here so you
start at at some frequency and as time
goes by you see the frequency is going
up it's it's you know the oscillations
are faster towards the end of the chip
compared to the beginning of it uh and
and and you do that for some time
duration T which is your big T which is
your trip duration and then you send
another one so you send a trip another
chip and all of these are the exact same
but the point is you're continuously
transmitting right there's no dead time
there's no stop time or silence time uh
for your uh for your transmitter another
way of visualizing this which is uh
perhaps uh more intuitive is if you plot
the instantaneous frequency of your
signal as a function of time it has this
linear ramp right so at Time Zero it
starts at some F0 frequency goes up with
a slope of B so you get to F 0 plus b
times T where Big T is a chip duration
and then you repeat right again you drop
back to F0 go up and so on so you send
these Sawtooth like frequency chips as a
function of time okay
so how do we do ranging with this okay
so the echo that you receive
um
is always just a time delayed version of
what you transmit right it also depends
on angle of arrival and range its
amplitude but here uh we're we're
focusing on that time of flight so the
the piaco receive we can write we can
break it down into two terms if s of T
is that chip that chip waveform that we
transmit you receive Echo has some angle
and range dependency times s of T minus
Tau right
so uh if we look at the
received Echo and compare that to what
we transmit let's look at this picture
down here first because I think that's
very intuitive so there's two things
plotted here the green is as again that
that instantaneous frequency versus time
for what we transmit right it's just a
ramp
and then the echo that you receive
that's also I mean it's the same
waveform it's just delayed right so some
round trip time of flight has passed
some Tau and then you receive your Echo
and the echo is the exact same like in
terms of instantaneous frequency it's
going to have the exact same behavior
it's a linear frequency chart that is
just delayed in time that's the echo
that you receive so here there's this
very interesting relationship between
your transmitted uh pulse and the echo
that you receive which is if you compare
the instantaneous frequency of the two
it's going to be constant right this
Delta F here as we call it is constant
between the two and it's equal to the
slew rate B times the round trip time of
flight Tau
and we know tau is directly proportional
to range right so we know the round trip
delay is just two row over V so if you
plug that in you see that the difference
in the instantaneous frequency of what
you transmit and the echo that you
receive is directly proportional to
range right B is known B is a slew rate
that we choose and we use and we know V
is the speed of sound and if we measure
this Delta F which is the difference in
the instantaneous frequency of the
transmitted and received waves then we
can do ranging so the beauty of this
technique is that it kind of transforms
a Time estimation problem a time of
flight estimation problem to a frequency
estimation problem right now by finding
this frequency Delta F you can convert
that to time and you can convert time to
distance okay and as you might know
frequency estimation it's a problem that
has been studied for many many many
years in statistics and electrical
engineering so there are hundreds of
different interesting techniques for
frequency estimation and all of those
are now applicable to sensing just by
this little trick of Designing a very
interesting waveform
is the concept of ctfm clear how it
operates so now we just need to figure
out how do we extract so we have our
transmitted waveform we have a receive
waveform how do we extract this Delta F
if we can do it
just that piece figure that out then I
think we are on to something yes
she's on the blind time because isn't
that usually like the periodicy of how
long you're sending isn't T usually
equal to
that it's like two Romax over B
um
oh I see what uh you're talking about
this T right
okay let me first uh uh talk briefly
about blonde time blind time because I I
I I I didn't talk about it yet and then
I'll I will get to your question so that
there is always this blind time and
that's where a bit of time where you
receive the echo or the tail of it
basically overlaps with the next chip
that you're sending okay and this is a
source of confusion right it's it's kind
of like uh in the case of pulse Echo uh
the question that uh had which was like
if if your Echo that you're receiving is
after you have transmitted your next
pulse then you can't do ranging so this
portion is is always ignored okay or
sometimes a bit of a dead time is is is
is a bit of idle time is added between
transmitting two chips so so this
doesn't happen but then uh this question
you said isn't tea
chosen to be to Romex
over we uh well that was the case for
pulse Echo not for ctfm so actually for
cdfm you want to choose your T to be
much bigger
than 2 row Max over B so in comparison
this portion is actually negligible and
you can just throw out that part of the
signal and only work with the piece
where you know the signal is good so
that's that's the case okay
so in in terms of the system block
diagram of a pulse of a ctfm sonar this
is it most of it is familiar right on
the transmit side again you have your
local oscillator you have your waveform
generator which now generates these
frequency chips for you right it does
this from F0 to F0 plus b times T
continuously just does that you amplify
it you might or might not have your
Transformer in the path one big
difference here is that because you're
continuously transmitting in ctfm you
can't use the same transducer as
transmitter and receiver because it will
interfere with itself it wouldn't know
like what's the part that I was
transmitting what's the part I'm
receiving so usually you have a separate
receiver transducer and you have your
separate transmitter transmitter is
always transmitting the receiver is
always receiving receive signal as usual
you pass it through an amplifier let's
say it has some gain constant gain mu
and the magic really happens here at
this this block here this is the block
that extracts that Delta f for you
basically and it's actually a very
simple mathematical operation it turns
out that it's just a multiplication it's
also called a mixer
or a down converter
so we'll see the exact math behind it
but then out of this so you have to feed
it two things right it needs to have
your transmitted
uh waveform or chirp and it also needs
your received Echo right because it
needs to extract the difference in the
instantaneous frequency of those two so
if this is done right then this is what
we call S Sub IFI for intermediate
frequency this should be a signal uh
whose frequency is that Delta F which is
proportional to the time of flight Tau
if that's done right and then you filter
that you take that into through the ADC
and then you can do rate and ranging and
and bearing estimation and and the
digital domain
um
let's see how much time do we have
should we go through this no we're
almost out of time so we'll look at the
math next time but it's very simple it's
just a it's just a complex
multiplication and it extracts that
Delta f for you but this is a good place
to stop and then uh we'll finish the
discussion next time any questions
no all right